[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau cette ut échos le premier de
l'année 2017
et pour ce numéro nous allons faire un
point sur l'année 2016 à saint quentin
en yvelines
aussi nous rencontrerons des entrepôts
des entrepreneurs tourné vers l'avenir
voici le sommaire nous avons rencontré
olivier debeugny fondateur de jungua
custot dia l'entreprise
saint-quentinoise qui traduit des textes
financiers souhaitent exporter son
concept en asie ce qui cube ce qui est
mauvaise ou encore ski business day 2016
a été une année active sur le plan
économique pour saint quentin en
yvelines nous feront aussi le point
et puis nous avons interviewé grégory
bousseton co fondateurs d'infinity de
l'uimm à coignières une société
spécialisée dans la réalité virtuelle
mais tout d'abord faisons un point sur
le monde économique de saint quentin en
yvelines saint-quentin-en-yvelines ses
seize mille établissements français
internationaux près de 145 mille emplois
dans des secteurs d'activité diversifiés
c'est le deuxième pôle économique de
l'ouest parisien après la défense c'est
aussi le premier pôle commercial des
yvelines se sont 4,6 millions de m²
d'immobilier d'entreprise san quentin en
yvelines possède de nombre d'entreprises
innovantes nous avons décidé de
rencontrer olivier debeugny fondateur de
l'entreprise dubois custot dia c'est une
entreprise qui fait du machine learning
c'est à dire de la traduction de textes
à d'estimation financière bonjour
bonjour alors en quelques mots présenté
moi lingua que ce te dire merci lingua
que cette audience est une société qui
développe des moteurs de traduction
automatique sur mesure alors un moteur
de traduction c'est quoi google
translate ou google traduction c'est un
moteur de traduction
sauf que nous ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
développe donc des google traduction
spécifiquement pour le domaine financier
soit par type de document bien précis
soit pour des clients qui nous en font
la demande
alors quels sont les clients qui peuvent
vous faire ce type de demande
alors les clients sont souvent des
grandes institutions financières ou les
directions financières de grandes
sociétés
on a comme clients le groupe axa par
exemple ou des sociétés comme le groupe
rothschild le crédit agricole qui est
ici d'ailleurs à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines juste à côté
voilà ce genre de sociétés des sociétés
de gestion d'actifs comme sycomore asset
management où d'autres prennent ça 2011
création de l'entreprise 2015 salaires
2016 ça a été une année importante pour
vous expliquer moi oui mais écoutez nous
donc on a 2011 création de la compagnie
2014 fin 2014 lancement commercial et en
2016 on a vu notre on a effectué une
levée de fonds pour nous permettre
d'accélérer commercialement on a fait
d'énormes investissements marketing et
on a obtenu notamment à la fin de
l'année dernière le prix de l'agefi de
la fintec innovante de l'année 2016
ce conte ce ratage du coup à l'univers
des films tech vu qu'on ne travaille que
pour le secteur financier et que c'est
vraiment une application d'une
innovation au au secteur financier
alors qu'est-ce que ça rajoute en plus
d'être un des gagnants de la fim tech
vous êtes reconnu voilà ça ajoute de la
crédibilité on travaille beaucoup donc
avec des grands comptes et suite à ce
prix bien on a eu pas mal de contacts
pour relancer des projets pilotes au
sein d'autres grands groupes financiers
ont parlé du crédit agricole tout à
l'heure il y en a d'autres que je peux
pas encore citer parce qu'on est en
phase pilote mais d'autres d'autres
grandes banques célèbre en france en
particulier mais aussi à l'étranger
parce qu'on arrive à avoir une
visibilité à l'étranger également le
marché c'est vraiment à ce stade
l'europe allait parler moi un peu de
l'année 2010 est à venir qu'est ce qui
va se passer
alors 2010 est pour nous c'est l'année
où on va lancer deux nouveaux couples de
langues
donc aujourd'hui on couvre le français
l'anglais l'italien l'espagnol
l'allemand et on a fait un gros gros
effort de r&d pour pouvoir traduire le
japonais et le chinois également hélas
souvent dans une optique de
compréhension donc l'aller les
institutions financières veulent savoir
ce qui se passe bien même vous voulez
acheter une société en chine il faut
traduire les rapports finaux vous l'êtes
vous devez traduire 50 rapport financier
pour faire une analyse si vous faites ça
en traduction humaine ça va vous coûter
une fortune
donc vous pouvez traduire tous
immédiatement donc le pour nous
l'objectif 2010 est c'est vraiment
l'asie et les langues asiatiques
donc j'espère là dans quelques semaines
pouvoir sortir nos premiers modules pour
le japonais
et on se met à travailler d'arrache-pied
sur le chinois on a déjà aussi commencé
à tisser des liens avec quelques banques
chinoises installées à paris pour pour
nous lancer sur saône sur ce marché là
et bien merci merci beaucoup
saint quentin en yvelines deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien su
développer ses compétences pour aider
des entreprises en 2016
il est temps de faire un point sur les
moments phares de cette année
l'agglomération a souhaité mettre un
coup de boost au monde de l'entreprise à
tous les niveaux en 2016
on débute avec le forum au métier qui
s'est déroulée le 12 février à
guyancourt qui avait mis l'accent sur
les jeunes et tous les secteurs
d'activité étaient représentés il ya
beaucoup de ses fans donc de centres de
formation des lycées professionnels qui
représentent les métiers de la bouche le
métier en lien avec l'automobile
il ya aussi des représentants d
la sécurité des armes et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines terre
d'innovation et bien l'agglomération l'a
prouvé avec notamment plusieurs
événements comme avec le camp d'été pour
les futurs ingénieurs de l'estaca qui
s'est déroulé en juillet dernier c'est
super intense mais ça fonctionne c'est
génial c'est une méthode vraiment qu'il
vient d'arriver en france
c'est un des premiers stages qui est
fait en france aujourd'hui est ce qu'on
peut produire en une semaine c'est
incroyable des cabines et pourra mettre
des mois pour le faire et c'est vraiment
révolutionnaire ça décuple les capacités
de chacun décuplez le réseau de chaque
entrepreneur c'était aussi l'une des
volontés de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines avec le sky business
day qui s'est déroulé en octobre dernier
le but mettre en relation des petites
entreprises face à des grandes
entreprises lors de speed dating
résultats 550 entreprises présentes et
plus de 3600 speed dating organisé c'est
un moment exceptionnel pour les
entreprises les gros soucis bien sûr que
si on veut amortir cette journée
et bien entendu que il faut mettre un
peu de méthode et 30 minutes vous devez
être capable d'avoir un échange et que
les deux parties en 30 minutes de savoir
si le produit que vous vendez et est
adapté aux besoins de l'entreprise ça
suffit tranquille mais et ça oblige bien
sûr ne peux te retrouver à faire un
effort aussi de simplification de bien
présenter en termes de marketing lors
leur plus concurrentiel soutenir les
jeunes entreprises c'est l'une des
missions du ski tube l'établissement
situe à guyancourt a vu le jour en
décembre et sa mission est simple être
un accélérateur de croissance est au
tout début de son projet lorsque
l'entreprise dit pas encore créé ou
qu'elle vient juste d'être créée que les
clients ne sont pas encore là que le
produit se cherche encore
on appelle ça une phase d'amorçage early
stage en anglais le ski cube sera à ses
côtés sera probablement son son
partenaire j'allais dire principal
il n'exclut pas les autres bien sûr
qu'ils sont mobilisés à travers le
réseau de bus n'occupe dont on parle et
le besoin de financement est un enjeu
important développement d'une entreprise
c'est pour cette raison que sky invest a
vu le jour en fait aujourd'hui avec
cette plateforme de financement
participatif soit sous forme de prêt
soit sous forme de participation au
capital
on peut aller de 100 mille euros jusqu'à
un million d'euros
peut-être plus il ya un vrai engouement
pour ce dispositif et en plus ça
présente l'avantagé de donner une
réalité territoriale et l'année 2010
cette réserve aussi plein de rendez vous
important pour le monde de l'entreprise
rendez-vous qui permettra 50 en libye de
garder son titre le terre d'innovation
vous avez pu voir toutes les actions qui
sont mises en place par l'agglomération
pour nos entreprises
faisons un point sur une entreprise
tournée vers l'avenir
infinité dreams située à coignières une
société qui est axée notamment sur la
réalité virtuelle
alors je suis avec eux green way
bousseton le responsable le co
fondateurs d'infinity dream
alors est ce que votre concept a pour
objectif de faire rêver les gens
tout à fait donc tous les jours on
étudie la question notre but du jeu
c'est pouvoir un peu nous tester rios
risée du monde quotidien
et c'est de se détendre par le biais de
la réalité virtuelle cas notamment été
prouvé récemment un peu partout lors du
forem aussi du forum du crs à las vegas
quel est le concept de votre votre
entreprise alors nous en fait on est
infinité dreams est un centre multimédia
de détente et de réalité virtuelle et
d'exploitation donc on travaille sur
tout ce qui est immersion en réalité
virtuelle
on produit aussi certains programmes en
réalité virtuelle notamment un peu de
production de vidéos pour le marketing
on propose aussi tout ce qui est sur les
phobies un petit verre par exemple si on
a la peur du vide on vous permet un peu
de travail et votre vertige
donc c'est plusieurs étapes pour éviter
de payer des gros forfaits qu'on a des
phobies et directement après on va vous
dirigez sur des professionnels atteint a
terminé à terminer programme nous ont
offert des petites étapes avant alors
vous vous êtes lancé en septembre
pourquoi avez vous commencé ce projet
alors pourquoi donc on est plusieurs
libre penseur entre autres on a une idée
en commun déjà nous personnellement on
aime concrétiser nos rêves et on a vu ça
un peu comme un rêve commun et on l'a
mis en place parce qu'on retrouve qui a
pas mal de d'activité en relation avec
la réalité virtuelle
c'est assez pratique même en termes de
formation et de perfection vous êtes
encore une entreprise jeune tout à fait
une entreprise jeune et on espère
prendre de l'ampleur dans les temps à
venir
assez assez prochainement
vous avez dit en dehors d'une table ou
qu'on vous considérez comme avant
gardiste c'est le mot qui vous qualifie
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on nous a dit
souvent même dans les forums donc il ya
six mois quand je suis arrivé à paris
lors du forum de cap digital que
j'aurais dit on a ouvert un centre
multimédia ils sont restés un peu ils
sont un peu resté surpris et directement
j'ai pu échanger toutes sortes de toute
sorte de vision sur la réalité virtuelle
avec des professionnels du milieu
notamment des personnes de laval
donc on a vraiment été très bien
aiguillé ça nous a permis de fignoler un
peu des angles c'est trop tôt pour un
chiffre d'affaires un peu trop tôt il ya
un peu trop tôt il faudra revenir vous
voir dans quelques mois d'ici quelques
mois où on pourra vous donner un petit
suite
sur le chiffre d'affaires et quels sont
les grands objectifs d'infiniti dream
dans les prochains mois alors si
possible déjà ouvrir un ou deux autres
clubs augmenter notre notoriété faire
des levées de fonds et si possible plus
tard être à l'international vous êtes
aussi sur le concept de l'hologramme si
j'ai bien compris de l'hologramme on
étudie la question parce qu'il ya pas
mal de systèmes sur le marché nous
engueuler meilleur donc en prendre
d'autres tentes partout autant propose
de la lévitation donc en propose aux
bijoux de clio parfumerie au magasin de
vêtements de faire léviter soient leurs
vêtements soient leurs objets en même
temps de pouvoir les faire pivoter toute
la journée et ce qui est énorme
on peut le faire aussi avec une enseigne
et ça ça n'existe nulle part en france
donc voilà on est les premiers je suis
assez fier de le dire avec notre équipe
qu'on est les premiers à proposer à
lévitation en france vous avez déjà des
pistes peut-être des clients potentiels
bien sûr donc on est en train de se
renseigner auprès de jean paul gaultier
quartier au channel
donc il ya tellement de possibilités
qu'il n'y a pas de limite aussi sur la
clientèle c'est les premiers sont les
bienvenus donc je pense c'est plutôt à
savoir qui veut être le premier
travailler avec le festival de cannes ça
pourrait être une possibilité
ça pourrait l'être mais on connaît une
société dont on est en train de créer un
partenariat qui est diversion
aujourd'hui et avant pick up vers dont
la confondent actrice et kamilou couteau
qui a organisé le festival de cannes qui
est le premier cinéma en france et on a
pu se rencontrer lors d'un forum et et
on va sûrement faire un partenariat
cette année proposer des programmes
similaires des programmes c'est à dire
par exemple comme sonar parce qu'il ya
il ya du cinéma il ya du théâtre il ya
de la 3d il ya tellement de noms de la
visite et que je pourrai pas en en un
seul instant vous le décrire donc si je
comprends bien vous avez des activités
ici à coignard mais vous voulez
externalisée également vos activités
tout à fait c'est le but le but c'est
qu'ils aient des infiniti dream partout
que ce soit le futur centre multimédia
qui permet de se détendre
ou de soie de s'enrichir en terme de
savoir on aura toujours du nouveau et
toi de quoi vous surprendre merci
beaucoup et bousseton et bon courage
pour l'implantation du futur centre
peut-être à paris peut-être à taïwan
peut-être aller au bout du monde
merci beaucoup merci de nous avoir
suivis pour ce 7 8 et cours bonne soirée
à tous
[Musique]